pour sa sixième édition le salon des
vins et des saveurs et des couleurs de
maurepas rassemble chaque année des
producteurs de toute la france et de la
région
nous sommes une des plus anciennes
pisciculture de france donc nous
produisons en fait sur place différentes
sortes de produits surtout à base de
truffe
l'association lions club maurepas 50 ans
living doyen a toujours le même objectif
reverser les profits du salon à une
action caritative
ça dépend des années bien sûr mais on
arrive à sortir à peu près on va dire
entre 7000 et 8000 euros et qui nous
permettent d'avoir des actions
intéressantes et importantes dans
l'année 62 exposants ont fait le
déplacement pour ce salon des vins des
saveurs et des couleurs
je trouve ça bien de pouvoir montrer son
travail et tout en courant participer
à une action caritative créateur de
lampes de mosaïque de bijoux c'est aussi
l'occasion de trouver des idées cadeaux
à la proche des fêtes de fin d'année je
crée des petits objets donc des petites
pochettes tous hors de mon atelier qui
est chez moi tout est fait intégralement
par mes soins
je crée des boucles d'oreilles également
pour oreilles percées et non percée
puisqu'il n'ya pas mille demandes dans
les yvelines
durant tout le week-end les exposantes
accueilli les visiteurs
ce salon s'inscrit dans la vie locale
j'essaie de venir tous les ans parce que
je trouve que les gens qui viennent
exposer coiffer des bons produits des
artisans pour la plupart je trouve que
c'est important plutôt d'aller faire ses
courses dans les grandes surfaces et
j'espère qu'il va continuer longtemps
un événement à retrouver tous les 2e
week-end de novembre à maurepas